greetings apiece welcome to the Dean
show if you haven't subscribed already
subscribed right now we have an exciting
show for you today
you know the fastest-growing ethnicity
in America are the Latinos Brazilians
included in this and you know what way
of life they're gravitating towards when
we come back we have our next guest is
going to fill us in on why the Latinos I
love in this way of life provides the
answers to why you've been created where
you're going when you die and that's
satisfaction that you're looking for in
the heart that's empty it fills that
void and the tinos have figured it out
and it goes back to their roots that's
right
so when we come back here to Dee's show
we got an exciting episode I'm going to
answer this question don't go anywhere
this is the small eco my alaikum salam'
motel about a cat I think we gave it
away I was opening up I said you know
left it as a guest gets which way of
life but people are looking at you maybe
think you know we with the greeting
maybe people figured it out with the
beard or found Allah maybe though so
what is it what is this way of life that
when Latinos Brazilians included when
they look back to their roots like the
African Americans they want to connect
they go back they want to figure out
their heritage they go back many of them
like Dave Chappelle went back to Africa
and Kunta Kinte he's calling on God
Almighty Allah and they figured out this
is our roots Islam Latinos same thing
here same thing you know it's a
beautiful thing a lot of Latinos what
they're doing now is they're they're
rediscovering the roots they're reading
about Islamic Spain and even for myself
you know doing some research you find
that Muslims dominated Spain for seven
hundred eighty years almost eight
centuries and you look at your name then
your name like Medina last names like
Medina even Guadalupe like my last name
Alvarez but banal casada you start
asking yourself where these names come
from and and a lot of a good popular
thing to do nowadays can trace your
lineage a lot of people doing that with
those DNA tests and stuff and people are
discovering you know a part of my
heritage traces back to Spain and it
don't even make sense right because the
Spanish when they came to to this part
of the world to colonize they had
Muslims with them you know we see in
Columbus
Columbus came when with ships that were
originally owned by Muslims right and
they had Muslims on there who were
guiding them directing them to come here
and so you people are starting to
rediscover the fact that masha'Allah
there's Muslims or part of my heritage
is from Islam and it starts triggering I
can interest to want to know more about
what is Islam so it's a beautiful thing
there the people are rediscovering
reconnecting with who they are how much
so Latinos are the fastest growing
ethnicity in America correct then
statistics showing and in the census
they are they done a study and they're
finding out that Latinos are the fastest
growing population in America and the
beautiful thing is within that they are
also the fastest growing population
within Islam many many Latinos are
leaving their former former religions
primarily Catholicism for whatever
reason and they're connecting with Islam
and hunger that I had the opportunity to
you research it myself and there's
numerous reasons why they're
reconnecting or they're they're
discovering Islam so it's definitely
amongst the Latinos Islam is the fastest
growing religion yes and you actually
you look back into it you discovered all
these things you also came from a what
background my family is originally from
Ecuador Ecuador yes South America but
they were they were of the Christian
faith yeah my actually my parents are at
work Affleck Catholic and they raised me
as a Catholic and hum do that they live
after studying a stellar learning about
Islam they've also embraced Islam soon
yeah we spoke we had your story you know
some time ago and so you went through
this journey yeah and how you do you
feel the more you look into it the more
Islam is providing all those answers
those deep questions that people really
seek out the purpose what's the purpose
of life you know why am I here in this
world fills that void in the heart
absolutely I mean as the majority of
Latinos they're raised Catholic like we
said and they're taught the belief in
God their belief in God that he's one
that he is the creator and he's a
Supreme Being but then there's something
else within that that kind of
throws a tangent the belief in the
Trinity and the Saints and how do you
kind of correlate every single aspect of
that religion and still make sense that
it's much in theirs it's monotheistic
and for myself in many Latinos it
doesn't make sense
so when they when they're introduced to
Islam and the fact that Islam actually
incurred or actually teaches true
monotheism meaning worshipping God alone
there's no other associates no not
nothing else with him no other partners
they start telling themselves what I was
taught originally as a child through
Catholicism this is the true
implementation here another example is
the Virgin Mary
she's depicted as a woman with a veil
when you look at any other religion in
America you rarely would see that except
in a Muslim summit practice with the
Muslims with the Muslim women wearing
hijab and as a matter of fact my
grandmother would tell us that when she
used to go to church in Ecuador they
were required to wear a veil and so when
she saw that my mother started wearing a
veil she started seeing that wow this is
the truth this is where they truly
practice that which they taught you know
there's so many other aspects some
family values islam teaches and
encourages family values for example
when allah mentions and worship allah
alone and be kind and be kind to your
parents and don't ever raise your tone
towards them and show them mercy the way
they showed you mercy as a child in the
quran mentions this and families in
latino families are very very close i
mean your neighbor is thought to be your
cousin you you you basically treat them
as your cousin you bring them in syria
and so when they see that the family
values especially in this time where
society is trying to remove family
values you mean it's very rare where my
families now meet at a table to eat in
islam it encourages that that love and
that respect and that admiration for
each other in the family so when that
sino see that that's part of islam
they're drawn to that i mean there's so
many other things language there's so
many things that you can talk about that
that reads the reason why I Latinas are
starting to discover Islam as the true
way of life you know and another example
with language it says that statistically
it said that about 4000 words
originally from Arabic and in Spanish
words originally from Arabic for example
like I'll hold on I'll cotton in Arabic
for example algebra algebra algebra
there's so many things like even when I
discovered like where my name came from
Guadeloupe a part of it is where the
valley and Lupe which is a Latin word
for for wolf it blew my mind I was like
wow this is who who we are and many
people are doing that and it's just an
amazing feeling when you when you find
that connection
yeah so really just going back to the to
the original way original way that's it
the pure organic original way when you
go back and you look back to your
history the Latinos look back it links
back to Islam absolutely absolutely and
it makes sense you know as we mentioned
Muslims were in Spain for so long they
left their influence if you if you ever
vacation in Spain you see messages that
are now have been changed to churches
because of the change in in the
government but they're still there their
influences is their Arabic writing is
all over the wall so when they're
rediscovering that they're asking us of
the question okay well where else what
else is there if maybe my ancestors my
great-great-great grandfather's were
Muslim then what is it about Islam that
you know that that um that the reason
why they practice it why why is it that
they did that so I want to ask myself
and many people are doing that and
you're coming into Islam we've got a lot
more to talk about this is an awakening
of the mind and the soul so we can
really be upon the truth and we can
really get that peace that we're all
looking for and we get the purpose in
life why we're here and we're discussing
the fastest-growing ethnicity Latinos
and the way of life that they're drawn
to because it's in their roots it's in
their history we'll be right back with
more here in the detail don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the D show
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the dish
by making a donation in the link below
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about the Latino roots now I say
Brazilians included they're included in
his bunch right yes cuz they're one of
my favorite groups also you know we
train you also trained the Gracie
Brazilian Jujitsu yes and we have a lot
of really nice people there also Latinos
the Brazilians and I wanna there was
actually interesting picture health
Gracie you've heard of him yes people
are seeing it right now he's actually in
atho and he's in front of a mustard and
it says he's seeking the blessings of
God yeah and I've gotten a chance to
talk with him he's a fabulous individual
and some people's faces you know they
just lights up it's like the fitrah
inside that God has placed in all of us
right that spiritual chip and when God's
name is mentioned you talk about the
pure natural way because Islam is just
it just makes sense worship the Creator
not the creation you're not worshiping
any of these sayings dead people in the
ground doing these strange superstitions
weird stuff that push people away from
religion right correct so they get drawn
into this do you also have this
experience absolutely and this is one of
the reasons a big reason why Latinos are
embracing Islam you know there's a it's
that direct connection there's no no in
between there's no intermediary you know
there's no asking other people for help
and you know for example confession and
stuff like that so many Latinos when
they discover the fact that it's just
you and God and you can ask him for
whatever help you need you know you can
ask him for forgiveness and it's just
direct your forehead on the ground and
that's it that's what people are looking
for Latinos are a big part of that
because they have that sense of faith
they have that sense of faith from their
upbringing and the fact that they
discover that they don't there there
isn't any need for hierarchy you don't
need to be a scholar or a leader of a
message or a mosque to have that direct
connection it just be me and you the
normal guy having having
direct connection that deep rooted
connection it's a satisfaction to the
soul for sure that definitely that
definitely connects now the jewel so
some people have a an infinity now they
a deep love for Jesus peace be upon him
and they don't know that it's a pillar
of faith to believe in Jesus but now can
you distinguish because people are group
they grow up in the Latin countries
believing that he was God literal son of
God right what do you say about this
when when I'm talking to Latinos and and
we're speaking about Islam you know
letting them know about Islam and we
bring up the topic of Jesus because they
ask how do you what is your relationship
with Jesus well how does Islam view
Jesus and we simply tell them I follow
Jesus example more now than I did before
I love him more now than I did before
and then when they ask you know how is
that possible and we share with them the
the story of Jesus from the Quran from
the Islamic point of view and they see
that there is a correlation with what
they know it's a it draws the manager
it's an it's an attention-grabber draws
that main and one wanting to know more
and especially when we explain to him
explain to them the fact that we believe
that Jesus was a messenger and prophet
and we clarify from our point of view
the the understanding of of this this
concept of the Trinity Trinity as
Muslims we don't we don't believe in
that because we don't associate Jesus as
part of God or one of three we believe
him as a man who came with this message
just like all the other prophets and
messengers and for the mind it's simpler
to grab it's just an easier concept to
understand and they begin to because
they already have that love for him they
realized Muslims also have that love and
they actually play the part you know and
so they begin to draw more into into
that aspect then and learn more about
Islam there was a famous football player
a soccer player that just accepted Islam
and he gave his thirteen reasons of why
he became Muslim and he said Islam
actually guided me well he actually what
he said exactly what was the dead
Jesus led me to Islam that's what it was
Jesus led me to Islam so then he gives
examples when Muslims see each other
they greet each other how Jesus greeted
with peace be unto you example you gave
him his mother blessed mother wearing
the veil yeah and more so the worship of
only God alone that's also in the Bible
but then someone says why don't I just
follow the Bible and just leave off the
things that I don't like from there and
stick where I'm at right when it comes
to the work the way I tell people and I
had this conversation with a co-worker
the other day is there's no doubt that
even even Christian scholars will say
that the Bible historically doesn't is
not a proven fact it's not it hasn't
been preserved just the way the way the
Quran was and many authors and sometimes
you don't even know who the author's
name was so for someone an individual to
take that book and say this is an
authentic book it's very difficult to
and no Christian scholar will admit to
that fact they say it's just divine and
divine inspiration divine words it's
it's something for the soul but we don't
want just something to have that that's
based on faith we want something that's
concrete - that's based on facts and
with Islam you get best of both worlds
it's a matter of having faith but you
also have the factual point that gives
you that surety that this is a religion
from God and it has been preserved and a
big example is the story of Jesus the
story of Mary in Moses and all these
historical figures that you find in
Latino religions whatever faith they
follow they find that and they begin to
ask themselves well let me look into
Islam and I'm doing that many many are
accepting Islam this is the updated
version now I'm updated it's just the
continuation it's as you some people say
it's it's the last chapter right it
still it's the last end of it and it's a
clarification for those questions that
many people have the common person will
ask themselves you know well what about
what about the Trinity how do you
explain that and if you're left just
with with someone telling you what you
just have to believe
for me it's hard like you can't just i
can't just believe if and though i used
to tell myself if this is god's divine
word his his religion the religion
everybody supposed to follow universe
religion then why is it so difficult to
understand why isn't it just clear-cut
when you look at Islam I mean it's you
know one plus one is two two plus two is
four it's clear it's the way it is and
and many people who give themselves the
time who open their minds and hearts to
it they will understand that fact it's
the way of life that has no more updates
to it it's been you know you get the
phone the iPad keeps updating updating
and if you want to go back to a prior
you can't even use it anyway but as long
as I don't worry of you it's the seal
the sealants that's it but and it's it's
a beautiful thing and you know one one
great thing is for many Latinos is that
there's a balance you know Allah is in
the Quran that verily we have made this
nation a balanced nation so there's no
need for you to be a specific title have
a specific title like for example a
priest or a nun to have a level of
religiosity you know there you don't
have to go to extremes and abandon the
world to be very religious no Islam it
teaches us balance and for Latinos when
they realize well I don't have to be
extreme in my belief I just have to
worship God alone and do what he has
commanded my five prayers my fasting pay
with I can the charity make Hajj you
know if I can make the pilgrimage if I
can and then that is enough for people
and they begin to realize that because
of that balance they want to embrace
that that's that's a true way of being
able to connect with Allah and I'm sure
you're starting to have infinitude to
this it makes sense absolutely it makes
sense as common sense worship the
Creator not the creation deep love for
Jesus but he was a mighty messenger and
never ever did he say in any version of
the Bible worship him or take him as a
literal son of God he was a servant of
God calling people to worship God that's
it we got some more to talk about with
you on the Deen show you're not going
anywhere are you I'm not going to be
right back inshallah
don't go anywhere please subscribe to
the D show follow
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the DS show now we originally
started talking about the roots the
Latinos have roots in Islam yes African
Americans have roots in Islam humanity
has roots in Islam because the first man
who was created Adam he was neither Jew
or Christian but he submitted himself to
God Abraham he didn't submit to anyone
in creation heed me here in any of these
religions but when he was told to do
what submit to the will of God that's
Islam isn't is that when I would have
this absolutely so let's go back a
little bit to Spain where now you had
the Muslims they were actually the
superpowers of the world yes and can you
take take because most people is a very
amazing topic and right and many people
don't know about you know the comfort
that use and Christians and humanity was
really you know a different level at
that time right you know it's um
historically and we know as Muslims that
after after the the death of the Prophet
peace be upon him many of his companions
took it upon themselves to start
propagating the message of Islam and
they took it to all the four corners of
the earth and not too long after his
death in about 70 80 years Muslims took
it to Spain and it was led by a man
named Tariq at INSEAD
and he took that it took Islam to Spain
and with the purpose of course of
spreading Islam and we know Islam or
beside Islam is peace Islam is
surrendering to Allah and when you see
the the impact that Islam had in Spain
780 years of governance and the amount
of contribution that Muslims made to
that society I mean medicine agriculture
irrigation engineering I mean you have
everything that came from that education
universities during that period when
when other other ethnicity or other
religions were in the Dark Ages
I mean you had a society flourishing and
the people who were within that society
also been
feted Jews and Christians that were
living within that society they
benefited from that as well and they
lived amongst the Muslims for almost
eight hundred years in peace benefitting
from those riches that Allah had
provided them because of the faith that
they were establishing there and and
even after the the Caliphate or the
tariff as they fell for whatever reason
you know the Christians they came they
took that over still you find it that
fronted an and isabella when they send
Christopher Columbus to the Americas
they sent them with Muslim ships ships
that were owned by Muslims Muslim
navigators using Muslim tool Islamic
tools Muslim tools that were for for
navigating and when they came here they
came here with Muslims so what happens
if Muslims also were here with with
Columbus and whoever else was here
obviously they began establishing their
culture their culture and their customs
etc so Islam has you know dipped his
hand it did its hand in everything or
humbly left by Allah's will and that's
one of the beautiful things and many
people don't know that many people don't
realize how how impactful Islam was for
eight hundred years and the level of
peace that it brought to anybody whether
you would you Christian even or not even
non-religious you didn't have any
denomination and Muslim it's an amazing
thing and what people realize that they
can see true Islam at its essence you
have some Latinos families because it's
spreading so quickly they end up seeing
their daughter who was out there being
promiscuous she was at the nightclubs
she was doing all sorts of things maybe
the son also and you know what they
really didn't raise havoc and now she
came home and she don't want to live
that life anymore
she don't want to be used and abused by
men she don't want to be a sex object
sex toy and now she's covered her
modesty they see this as something
strange she's they see her bowing down
her head five times a day and now they
start to you know correlate the two and
they see like look Muslims my daughter
oh my god how do you say oh my god in
Spanish adios adios what's going on
Tedder East oh what's happening here
right
have you seen this absolutely and it's
and I think it's just of is do more for
to negative information that is fed
through medias you'll find that many
many Latinos who embrace Islam they go
through that and for example and when I
told you it before I said when I
accepted Islam was do a difficult during
a difficult time the nation went to a
difficult time on 9/11 and my dad was
the same way my dad he said you know why
convert now Muslims are being harassed
why go through that and many women who
go who embraces them and are leaving
those old lifestyles of fun and games
and amusements and drinking and partying
all that stuff to a life full of peace
and and the fact is that they embrace
they embrace it fully covering
themselves the parents here they tend to
not understand it and more so it's just
a lack of education and I think it's a
great opportunity for us to share with
them and teach them about Islam but no
doubt that you find that there you know
and but it is what it is and I think is
just a great opportunity for so a good
example to a true story is where this
actually is happening and in one case
particular the daughter starts wearing
the modest dress right her character
starts getting better she's not coming
home late at night anymore
and she's developing yourself to be just
a better human being because that's
obviously what islam teaches now we know
that there's a lot of temptations out
there struggles so she starts to slip up
she starts going back to summer for old
ways and she ended up taking the hijab
off you know she was at peace when she
was practicing praying now whatever
happened she kind of drifted off the
parents now are actually they're not
Muslim but they're begging her to go
back right to where she was and she kind
of stuck in between two worlds now you
know this the the lifestyle that's
calling but she's miserable now yeah
right she's very unhappy and obviously
because you know when you leave the
medication for the soul when you
disconnect your heart from his maker
become sick again
sick again yeah yeah but my point here
was the family now in the beginning how
do you say it again oh my god adios
adios yeah hello my god
but now they've seen it in action Islam
in action the right way yeah they want
her back where she was in Islam you know
and it's it's interesting that you say
that it's because in the beginning when
when they reject her wanting to be a
good righteous Muslim is because of
those things that are unknown but then
when they see her falling back into
those into the wrong path um Latinos in
general they know what's right and
what's wrong
even just general its general ruin
humanity we know what's right and what's
wrong
lying is wrong stealing is wrong we know
that from just our own natural
disposition that is wrong and that see
knows the hard part is they don't want
them to leave their cultural you know
upbringing I don't want you to be Muslim
because then you're going to break the
family ties but in reality actually
Islam closes them and it's just a matter
of B not going to be able to be part of
that that that social spectrum again a
big issue uh you know they don't want to
partake in that fun or anything like
that and it's it's amazing how a family
member or a family members when they do
see them slipping they like put the back
on check to put to get back on the right
path you know and again I think the most
important thing in this opportunity for
the sister and for the family is to have
other Muslims that see non-muslims share
with them about Islam you know teach
them about Islam so that a situation
like this doesn't happen you've seen
families take a kick their kids out
because they embrace Islam but it's an
opportunity for us to open those doors
of communication educate people about
what Islam is and hopefully make sure
that you know things like that don't
happen you know your organization before
we cut out tell the world a little bit
about what you do in your organization
how they can get a hold of you if they
want you to come out and speak at an
event for Latinos well we started a
small nonprofit organization it's called
habla Moses LOM and
we've been doing this for quite some
time focusing on increasing the
resources about Islam in Spanish so
everything we do is strictly in Spanish
from translating articles providing
articles videos classes like we're doing
here at the at a local masjid and even
offering books for children one of our
biggest projects is creating resources
for children Latino children and as a
matter of fact during Ramadan we had a
great campaign raising some funds
through donations we were able to send
children's books to about ten countries
ten Latino countries so that they can
have those books for their Eid and so
this is one of the things that we're
doing small little tasks that we've been
we've embarked on and if they want to
know more about it they can visit our
website at www.opm.gov/tribalprograms
world but the heart is empty Islam feels
that war it void that's right and you
got one shot to get it right and you
can't just do it like Burger King your
way it's God's Way it's the creator's
way we will install I'll see you next
time subscribe if you haven't already
continue to tune in to the D show we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you